the third year of bungees community
splitting destiny has been announced and
goes by the name rise of iron during a
live stream the first trailer was shown
and a few details were given so i'll try
and condense them down now or than a few
minutes let's pause the trailer straight
away there this character is Lord
Saladin he's been rewarding multiplayer
gamers for years who knew he look like
that under his helmet I must admit I
thought he would look like Lennie James
from the walking dead you know the guy
who plays Morgan and he does to some
degree it turns out that Lord Shaq's
voice is money Jim's releasing worldwide
on sep tember 20th the game will cost
thirty dollars it's uncertain what it
will cost City Europeans are Australians
are any any other place in the world but
judging by their past DLCs we shouldn't
be getting ripped off too much rise of
iron looks like it's focused around the
competitive ayan van and multiplayer
element but brings it into sort of a
non-competitive PvE area and we've been
told to expect new campaign complete
with cinematic story new missions and of
course new quest lines we are getting
new enemies sadly it's not the Cabal
like the entire community has requested
a hundred times before this time it's
it's called the plague I believe it's
very much an evolution of the fall and
enemies you've killed about ten thousand
times before but these new splices and
devil splices have broken through the
Earth's defenses I eat a huge wall
holding the last city and now it's time
to fight them just like the iron laws
did back before we became guardians
speaking of the iron Lords gala horn is
back or is it yellow home orgy horn or
however it said I'm sorry if I offend
anyone by mispronouncing that at the end
of the trailer the most exotic of exotic
weapons has made its come back through a
pre-order bonus which has led the
community to go a little insane but
don't worry probably because the girl
horn was such an iconic weapon here to
win people were saying and in fact it's
really just a skin that the people who
pre-order are getting the regular golden
white jihan will be available to
everyone they'll be a quest in rise of
iron centered around reforging the gala
horn as the story goes Jihan was forged
with the armor of fallen guardians at
Twilight gap for players who have
supported the game since 2014 this is a
huge piece of law which the game is
built on the gala home was a hugely
overpowered weapon which wasn't taken
into year two but now it seems to be in
year three so I makes
in it to be nerfed sorry the new red has
been hinted at but I don't believe we
have enough information to speak about
it just yet but we have seen new weapons
and armor sets the armor in particular
has my attention three sets were visible
during the trailer the first being this
neon red ensemble modeled by a Titan the
second set looks to be the new trials of
Osiris set as you can see the Egyptian
theme can be seen on the breastplate
finally the third set looks to be the
iron banner armor as the Ironwood tree
is visible on the braces oh and did you
see the flaming axe at first it looked
like this was going to be an upgrade
from the sword which were brought in a
year ago but now it appears to be a
relic you will be able to use this
problem strike or read for a limited
time but with devastating use will
you'll be getting destiny the rise of
iron as a year one player I am excited
by the return of gala horn and the law
behind log Saladin and his story but i'm
unsure at the moment what do you guys
think sound off below if this video has
been useful please consider subscribing
all the best and see you soon